let's say that this rectangle this green
rectangle right over here let's say it
had an area of
268 square units whatever those units
are you could imagine them being square
centimeters or if you imagine this being
a big field that you're looking at from
space it could be square miles or
something so i'm just going to write
square
units
and let's say you knew the dimensions of
one side of the field so let's say that
you knew
you knew that this let me just color
let's see let's say you knew that
this side of the field right over here
the length of this side of the field is
two units two units and i haven't really
drawn this to scale if i wanted to draw
it to scale it would be like it would be
like much shorter it'd be like that but
you would have trouble seeing the
rectangle then but let's just assume
it's two units so if you know the whole
area is 268 square units and one side is
two units what's the other side going to
be what is the other side going to be
what is
what is
let me pick another color
what is this side
what is this side of this rectangular of
this rectangle this field whatever this
might be
what is the length of that side
well if you multiply these two sides you
get the area so if you start with the
area if you start with
268
268 and you divide by the other side
divide by the other side
you're going to get the length of this
side right over here so if we wanted to
figure out the length of that side it
would be 268 divided by 2. and you've
already seen or we've already seen
multiple ways to figure out what 268
divided by 2 is but the whole reason of
me drawing this rectangle or this arial
view of this field or whatever you want
to call it is so that we visualize it
using area and so one way to do it is is
to break up this 268 square unit area
into areas that are easier to imagine
dividing by two
so here i have the say i have the same
field but i've just broken it up so it's
the same field this dimension right over
here is still two units
two units but i've broken it up
this blue
area is 200 let me do that in a
in another color so this blue area
is
200 units this yellow area is 60 units
and this magenta area
is 8 units
now why is that useful
well now each of these it's much easier
to divide by two all i did is i took the
268 and i and i
and i said well look this is the same
thing as 200
plus 60
plus
60
plus eight i just broke up the 268 into
things that are easier to divide by two
and now i can take those things and
divide by 2. i could take each of them
and divide by 2.
so what is what is this
what is this dimension going to be
right over here actually let me do that
a different color
what is this dimension right over here
going to be
well two times that is going to be a
hundred so this is going to be 100 and
how did we get that we got that by 200
divided by 2. 200 divided by 2 is 100.
what's 60 divided by 2
well 60 divided by 2 is going to be
30. so this part of the field is going
to be 30 in that direction and 2 in this
direction and once again not drawn by
not drawn to scale
and then finally what's this section
going to be it's going to be
it's going to be
8 divided by 2 which is 4.
notice 100 times 2 is 200 30 times 2 is
60. 4 times 2 is 8.
and so this this whole length up here is
going to be 100 plus 30 plus 4 or 134
and we've already seen other ways of
coming up with this you say look two
hundreds divided by two is one hundred
six tens divided by two is three tens
eight ones divided by two is four ones
and that's exactly what we just did over
here but we visualized it using
this kind of a rectangle breaking it up
into chunks that are maybe easier to
imagine dividing by two we broke it up
into two hundreds
two hundreds right over here we broke it
up into six tens or sixty
or sixty right over here and we broke it
up into eight ones
eight ones we broke up the area and then
we took each of those areas and we
divided it by two to find that part of
the length and when you add them all
together you get the entire you get the
entire length
now that's just one way to do it where
you take each of the place values and
you break up your field or your
rectangle like that but you could do it
other ways you don't always have to
break it up that much for example
let's say
let's say that
this
let's say that
this area is
856 square units square
units
and let's say that this dimension right
over here
is 8
is 8 units
is 8 units
so how could we break this up so it's
easier to think about what the other
dimension would be what the length is
going to be and this length once again
is going to be 856 divided by 8.
856
divided by
eight is this length right over here
well you could break it up into eight
hundreds five tens and six ones but you
might notice well five tens it's not so
easy to divide that by eight but we can
divide 56 by eight we know that 8 times
7 is 56
so what you could do is you could break
this rectangle into the 856 square units
you could break it up into
800 square units and then another 56
and another 56 square units so once
again we broke it up into 800s and then
56 ones
and then 50
56
856 ones same area i just broke it up
and now if you say look this is eight
if you say
if you say this right over here is eight
well what is going to be
what is going to be
this length
what is this length up here going to be
well it's going to be 800 divided by
it's going to be 800 divided by 8. so
actually let me write it below it so 800
divided by 8 this length right over here
is going to be
is going to be
100 how did i get that i got eight
hundredths divided by eight is one
hundred eight hundred divided by eight
is one hundred and then you have this
other magenta part what is 56 divided by
eight well that's seven 56 divided by
eight this length right over here is
going to be 7. so what's this entire
length
what's this entire length well it's
going to be 100 plus 7 which is equal to
107. so once again you could have said
look 8 goes into 800 100 times 8 goes
into 56 seven times 107 why did sal draw
these rectangles well just so that you
can help some it's sometimes helpful to
visualize this says hey look you're
trying this is an area problem if this
is the total area if 856 is the total
area and 8 is one of the dimensions well
and then 856 divided by 8 is going to be
the other dimension
and one way when you're breaking this up
by place value you're breaking up the
numbers into pieces that are easier to
divide by eight
you could think of it as you're just
breaking up that area and you're just
trying to figure out parts of this
length so that's a hundred right over
there and then this right over here is
seven so anyway hopefully this this
broadens your visualization capabilities
when you are dividing multiple when
you're when you're doing division